to people who think locals like
humanitarian aid workers i would say
that this is not necessarily
true i wouldn't approach it in the sense
that
they will be automatically grateful that
you're here
they didn't really ask you to to come so
the best thing is to be humble
and let's not forget that the local
populations are often also aware of
the contradictory relationships that can
be
present especially from western
countries where they might be
involved in the conflict by selling arms
etc or supporting a certain side
so basically i would recommend actually
approaching local people with an open
ear and really try to listen to what are
their needs what they need
and to try to build a relationship with
the direct beneficiaries not necessarily
you know authorities or representatives
but really the people on the ground who
are really in the need
um i think it is important to build a
relationship with them
and to listen to them and at the end
this is actually the
fulfilling part or where you can
actually gain acceptance